los desastres naturales han estado en el
centro del debate en esta conferencia
del agua de la ONU porque la mayoría de
ellos están relacionados precisamente
con los recursos hídricos ya sea por un
lado las inundaciones o por el otro las
graves sequías y Ecuador ha sido una de
las víctimas más recientes de estos con
el ciclón yaku y no solo con esto sino
que el cambio climático y el
calentamiento del planeta está afectando
los páramos andinos Y es que 16 de las
24 provincias de Ecuador quedan sobre
este ecosistema al respecto hablamos con
Gustavo manrique el ministro de medio
ambiente de Ecuador y esto fue lo que
nos dijo entre el 2022 y 2022 en América
Latina y el Caribe han habido 175
catástrofes el 88% de ellas han sido a
causa del cambio climático o temas
climatológicos Mientras usted y yo
estamos hablando en este momento mi
ciudad Guayaquil está completamente
inundadas y sobre ese de 88% de
catástrofes que son razones
climatológicas
el 40% de las muertes a causa de eso
provienen de tema climatológico y el 71%
de las pérdidas económicas Entonces
no solo que que es que hay que salvar el
planeta sino que es un tema de perfil
social el ministro manrique también nos
explicó Qué clase de actividades están
haciendo para proteger el agua en su
país el 50% en promedio de la población
rural del Ecuador toma agua contaminada
con escherichia coli con ese fecales
Hablemos claro por qué Porque hay
actividades productivas aguas arriba que
no cuidan una fuente importante
geográficamente hablando donde se
produce agua y luego permea y abajo a
los gads les toca otra tabla o la dan
así entonces una forma de cuidar el
origen es creando una política pública
de conservación de páramos estas son
algunas de las acciones y los efectos
que está dejando el cambio climático en
América Latina